قال نائب رئيس الوزراء روسي الكسندر نوفاك
ان بلاده لن تبي عن النفط والمواد
البتروليه الا للدول التي تعمل وفق شروط
السوق حتى لو تسبب ذلك في خفض الانتاج
واكد نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي ان فرض سقف
على اسعار النفط غير مقبول وان روسيا تعمل
على وضع اليات لمنع امدادات النفط للبلدان
التي ستضع سقفا للاسعار وقال نوفاك ان سوق
النفط العالميه في وضع افضل من ما كانت
عليه منذ شهرين لكنه هناك حاله من الغموض
لا تزال قائمه بحسب قوله
تفضل علينا من موسكو مراسله الجزيره رانيا
تريدي رانيا هل تكشف تصريحات نوفاك عن
استراتيجيه روسيا لمواجهه قرار الدول
السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي واستراليا في ما
يتعلق بالنفط الروسي
في واقع الامر جلال يمكن القول ان موقف
روسيا استراتيجيه موسكو تجاه هذا القرار
قرار وضع سقف لاسعار النفط الروسيه يعني
هي واضحه منذ البدايه روسيا ترى ان مثل
هذه الخطوه هي خطوه غير مقبوله مرفوضه
بالنسبه لموسكو همم بشكل قاطع فضلا عن ذلك
همم يعني هذه تصريحات وهذا الموقف يعني
اكدت عليه ليس فقط اليوم اليكساندر وايضا
في وقت سابق الكريم لين الحكومه وحتى
الرئيس
هذه الخطوه بحسب بجانب الروسيه تنتهيك همم
شروط العمل في الاسواق تنتهي قواعد منظمه
التجاره العالميه ورئيس الروسيه اكد في
وقت سابق انه في حال تم اتخاذ هذا القرار
وهو ما حدث وهذا ما سيخلو ويضر البيئه
المصالح الاقتصاديه لروسيا فان روسيا في
هذه الحاله لن تقوم بتوريد لا النفط ولا
الغاز ولا الفحم ولا حتى زيت الوقود لاي
دوله اا يعني اتخذت هذا اروى هي ستتعامل
وفقا ل همم القرارات الروسيه فقط مع الدول
التي
ستتعامل مع روسيا وستقوم بشراء النفط منها
وفقا لقواعد الاسواق العالميه اا يعني
فانه اذا هو موقف موسكو واضح محدد تحدثت
عنه خلال الاشهر الماضيه همم مرارا ولكن
ايضا هنا بالفعل لابد من الاشاره لان
النظافه اشار الى ان الحكومه الروسيه
حاليا تقوم بوضع خطط واليات همم تمنع همم
روسيا من التعامل مع تلك الدول والتداول
معها تلك الدول التي وضعت شروط سقف لسعر
النفط الروسي هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى
بالفعل روسيا حذرت من انها عواقب وخيمه
ست- تسبب بها هذه الخطوه هنا اود التذكير
بتصريحات الرئيس الذي قال ان الازمه
الطاقه التي تمر بها الدول الاوروبيه
والاتحاد الاوروبيه حاليا بشكل عام لا
يعني هي ليست مرتبطه بتطورات وضع
بيوكرانيا بقدر ما هي مرتبطه بالقرارات
التي وصفها الخاطئ من قبل زعماء الدول
الاوروبيه وعليه فان هذه الخطوه ايضا ستصب
في هذا الاتجاه ستاد تضر بالاتحاد
الاوروبي اشار الى ان ذلك اولا سيتسبب
بحسب بجانب الروسي بحسب البيوت وايضا بحسب
بانو باك همم الى اولا نقص في موارد
الطاقه على الصعيد العالمي وارتفاع كبير
في الاسعار هذه الموارد